[Music]
well hello there watching The Press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mails consultant editor Andrew Pierce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
Kevin McGuire they will they'll be with
us rather from now until just uh before
midnight welcome to both of you
um probably been a long day for both of
your presume hasn't it anyway from Pages
uh the guardian leads with Liz truss's
speech to the conservative conference in
particular her description of the
party's critics as an anti-growth
Coalition The Daily Mail also leading
with the story the headline defiant Liz
takes fight to her critics
here's the eye a cabinet Rebellion
growing as it reports ministers are
encouraging the PM to reverse benefit
cuts and to link any increases with
inflation you turn or face election
Wipeout trust warned reads the front of
the times the Metro Rifts on the
introductory music for Mr truss's speech
asking moving and up or is it moving on
out Daily Telegraph looks at the prime
minister's Economic Policy their
headline income taxes to rise by 21
billion pounds despite that many budget
the financial times reports that the US
government is angry with the OPEC plus
group of petroleum exporting countries
after they agreed to cut their output
despite greater need owing to the war in
Ukraine
the son Hears A Manchester City player's
wife has offended monk unions by being
rude about the city's food
and the star has word of claims from the
world of Chess that a player used a
particularly novel method to cheat
not sure we're going to understand that
one are we but anyway
so reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out this front pages while
you listen to Kevin and Andrew so let's
go to them Andrew how did she do
well she did much better than I think
most people expected she's not a great
orator by any stretch of the imagination
North Carolina actually they're both
pretty boring both pretty wooden but
actually this speech she was much more
upbeat it was about 35 minutes which I
think is more than enough because it was
minus major policy announcements uh
she's not going to say anything about
more about uh interest rates because
that could spook the market so it was an
attempt to reassure the party Faith or
that she's got a grip to talk about the
direction she wants to take the party in
and she also talked a lot about herself
because people don't know who this trust
is and she talked about growing up in
Paisley growing up in Leeds being the
first British Prime Minister to have
been educated at a comprehensive school
all quite interesting a lot of stuff
people won't know I've known about this
uh and um and she said that she knew
growing up in a family which believed in
education in her father is a professor
of Applied Mathematics she knew when she
opened her first wages Bill the shock
when she saw how much the tax man's
taking well there'd be an even bigger
shock if she was opening that wage bar
now because the tax taken this country
is at its highest level for 70 years and
that's a terrible indictment on the last
couple of Tory governments I'm afraid
yes we'll come to the tax implications
despite that budget in just a moment but
um you know we saw the Ft there the
picture store on the front page you know
the paper of business talking about this
anti-growth Coalition I mean is that
confected is it you know do people need
to find somebody to battle to G up the
base
um Kevin you know or has she got a point
no I think she's just lumped all her
opponents together
labor liberal demographics liberal uh
SNP uh environmental groups trade unions
militant trade unions uh Chicago didn't
have Uncle Tom cobbly at all but it was
almost it was almost there wasn't it I
mean look she's she's just looking for
for opponents because she's
trouble serious trouble and uh of course
you know they're very tribal meetings
party conferences so of course Tories
don't want to be blaming themselves they
want to be blaming others but yeah as
the guardian put it the new common enemy
well it's yeah the rest of Britain is
really what she was saying I what's so
sure that's very wise putting yourself
against everybody else because there are
more of them than there are you but I
listen to that speech I think the best
you could say if you were being really
kind to her is it was
woman-like uh that would be the best it
could say and that shows you how
father Tories have fallen and what a
torrid time they've had in the 10 days
since nata
special Financial operation that
backfired so uh spectacularly and if you
stabilized the party it's been
stabilized rather like a car crash
victim on a hospital trolley they're
just stopping them hemorrhaging blood
but yeah they're so far behind in the
polls now and they're at war with each
other in her uh you know her anti-growth
Coalition I think she could probably
stick off the cabinet loads of
ex-ministers and many MPS in our own
party I mean that is the problem with
that is sure she's managed to isolate
herself absolutely incredible new
leaders normally get a honeymoon she's
gone straight for the divorce yeah but
that we saw the guardian their common
enemy uh the daily mail your paper back
on track I suppose after that get a grip
headline uh defiant Liz takes the fight
to her her critics but just on her
delivery just quickly you know she
admitted during her the hustings and
everything she wasn't the best orator
but um and one person from conference
you know this evening praised her
Clarity and simplicity but occasionally
it was a bit more play school than plain
English wasn't it we just need a bigger
pie
um big government makes people feel
smaller I mean it was it was so basic
you know it's the contrast with Boris
Johnson when he had to go to your
thesaurus to work out what he was
talking about your Latin lectures
um do you know you know how do you feel
she gets her message across because of
this delivery issue
well I think it's a problem and I and I
think because Boris could speak of this
great soaring rhetoric he was a great
Wordsmith Theresa May was pretty
hopeless actually as well
um uh and I think I mean I think she got
got through it today and it was probably
the best speech I've heard her make but
I do think she needs to get some passion
in her belly and some passion in her
voice uh because she does feel
passionate about issues she feels
passionately about these wretched trade
unions bringing bringing Britain
grinding to all the train drivers who
earn on average 59 000 pounds a year on
strike overpay today uh causing huge
disruption to all sorts of other small
businesses and making it difficult for
people to get to work and those wretched
Extinction Rebellion protesters she
singled them out too uh but I but she
still quite new at this Mrs Thatcher was
a pretty full public speaker at the
start of her Premiership and she got a
lot better so I'm hoping that she is
going to do take voice lessons and
breathing lessons which is what Mrs T
did and I think I think probably a lot
of politicians do because projection and
communication is so important now
particularly in the in an age of 24-hour
news bulletins uh it's so important much
more important than there ever was
before yes and you know everyone
talks about the previous American
elections don't they of the first
televised address but as you say
politicians are everywhere now we see
them on all mediums your paper picks up
on the enemies of Enterprise you know
this anti-growth Coalition the eye talks
about
um the enemies from within effectively
cabinet Rebellion growing
um and you know are there still those
who who suggest you know who who voted
for this deregulatory free marketeering
government Kevin this isn't what the
vote in 2019 was actually about you know
the Mandate uh from the country but the
Mandate also from those politicians who
are in her own party and uh as they head
back to Westminster next week
no in in some ways trust is the
aberration uh in recent conservative
governments now I've got a huge
criticisms of what they did and what
they claimed to do but Cameron May
Johnson all wanted to be compassionate
concerned conservatives in in some way I
don't think they delivered it I often
think they showed it in a very very bad
way but she's lacking that Compassion or
any emotional connection and there's a
large group of her MPS who now see she
is weak she only got about a third of
them to become leader uh Rishi soon had
got more although he didn't get half but
he got more and she's pretty isolated in
Westminster they've also seen she's weak
and she makes terrible mistakes which is
what happens with that uh special
Financial operation of 45 P tax she
u-turned so they're going to push and
push and push to try and uh uphold the
promise to increase Universal Credit and
that's that's remember 49 of the
households I get it or in work so that
they they get an uplift in line with
inflation which is roughly twice the
rate of of earnings if she cuts at that
about five billion a family two parents
two kids would lose a grander year a
thousand pounds so she's really got
battles on that that's before we get to
immigration where she's clearly going to
split with her home secretary sirilla
bravaman who's talking really tough
while she can see uh trust that Britain
needs skills and the skilled people come
in uh add to the economy enhance enhance
the country
um but she's going to then get into a
battle with a with a brexit lot no she's
got a terrible time ahead and uh I think
the art the I guess at the times that in
a way have got a similar splash
about your U-turn or you'll be defeated
you'll be
um defeated again and you're going to
get that election wiper it's it is
incredible over 10 days to watch a
governing party to be in power for 12
years literally collapse in front of
your eyes that's what I say over two
years ahead before the likely general
election there are events that may
somehow rescue the conservatives but it
does feel at the moment is it as if
there is a change in the National mood
and it has a change against trusts and
quartang and Rhys MOG and quaten Trust
Reese MOG just can't grasp why well it's
because they're out of touch people
aren't looking for a small state they're
looking for a state that will protect
them and promote their interests yes and
they've got used to that during covid
they need that Comfort during this
economic and energy crisis coming up so
you know that there are timing issues
with these policies um Andrew certainly
for many people but in terms of the
conservative party of whom as we know
many did not choose her as their first
choice candidate in those first round of
voting and earlier this summer
um how many of them will vote down these
policies despite the brutal whipping
where we're being told to expect you
know what what is it is it 34 MPS now
only have to vote against her policies
or the budget even
I think it's 35 or 36 actually and then
she was she was told on Sunday that 36
had already been reached so that was the
end of the 40p cutting tax the 45p
cutting tax rate B what's going on with
the upgrading of benefits um no decision
had been taken anyway there was an
indication she was minded to raise
benefits well welcome back you're
watching the Press preview with me now
Andrew Pierce and Kevin McGuire welcome
back to both of you
um very worrying headline in the
guardian uh Poland uh wanting U.S
nuclear weapons uh we're watching the
war in Ukraine with great Fascination uh
ukrainians certainly making Headway in
at least two parts of their country now
but this is concerning is it not the
ratcheting up in terms of nuclear Kevin
it is and hopefully the US will resist
and not send nuclear weapons on the
Polar territory but the Poland's
president feels they would uh they they
would be safer with them because Belarus
has changed its Constitution to allow
Russian nuclear weapons to be cited on
its territory although I don't believe
any any have been cited there yet and
may not but no it's a you the last thing
we want is nuclear escalation uh here
the Americans have looked at it before
and would be very nervous about it and
cautious but with Putin's back against a
wall that uh mobilization of 300 000
extra soldiers trying to stem those
Ukrainian uh attacks that had retake in
their their territory Russians uh fleen
I understand why Poland will be nervous
because of course it's there in the
theater and much nearer than we are here
in the UK and until 1991 uh was part of
the Soviet Union it had been been
occupied and taken into the in that
Empire they're they're free now they
don't want to go back but it's uh it is
concerning because Putin is going to be
very very desperate
um let's look at page six of the Metro
I've just noticed that the Princess of
Wales is wearing a dress almost
identical to Liz trust but um they might
have cropped destroying let's have a
look
oh I know anyway it's about it's about
Iran the the story we're chosen I think
we've probably cropped it oh yeah we've
cropped it we will we'll we'll see the
Princess of Wales another time but
anyway
um you know the extraordinary scenes in
Iran um now uh young people it's got a
young population as well Andrew you know
how significant This Is How brave these
people are and so on but um you know
this is this is something to behold is
it not
it really is and um it's all reflected
it's all because of the murder or death
in prison of the young woman 23 who was
wearing her clothes properly they didn't
suit the the the the the the
the standards of the what are those
police called there's a poor business
reality yeah the morality the morality
Place yeah terrible so women have
literally taken to the streets they're
ripping up their clothes but they're now
increasingly passing their hair cutting
their hair as part of a part of the
protest and it's and it's spreading all
over Iran and you do wonder how this is
going to be put down by the Iranian
authorities is the is the is the big
repressive uh fist gonna come smashing
down on the protesters
um because
um you suspect it could backfire
um but I think these women in particular
being incredibly brave because their
risk imprisonment run out of time Andrew
I'm sorry thank you both thank you